oh  last question dr dallin are you sure the  perimeter surrounding the zone is really  enough if a powerful emission were to  occur we would listen  the zone has remained stable for years  besides we didn't establish the most  advanced institution in human history  without first guaranteeing its safety  as the head of the scientific institute  for research of the chernobyl area or  circa for short i believe the wonders  that we will bring to the world far  outweigh the potential risks  how big are these risks exactly  the zone reveals a whole new world  we can stick with the old one fearing  change  but tell me  do you want our descendants to remember  us as cowards  or as those who dared to venture forward  to a new better humanity  the injured were evacuated i remind our  listeners that a similar incident  happened in our region quite recently  ruining homes and livelihoods  however city officials urge people to  stay calm assuring them the situation is  totally  team  you